all right joining me now is Ari fler
former White House Press Secretary Fox
News contributor and Chris Bedford
executive editor of the Common Sense
Society Ari now Obama decides to come
out and warn that 2024 may be at risk
what do you think is behind
that well he knows Joe Biden remember he
is the one who said that Biden didn't
need to run he didn't need to take this
chance and to do it in 2020 and I don't
think Barack Obama has ever been
impressed by Joe Biden and so it's a
warning signal to other Democrats and
Laura I think there is a 5050 chance
maybe you one and three chance that Joe
Biden is going to get dumped by the
Democrats at the republ at the
Democratic Convention in August you look
at Democrats Senators congressmen the
people who have to run for reelection do
they really want an unpopular
81-year-old at the top of the ticket
right before the election and they have
a chance at a convention to do something
about it pay a lot of attention to
what's going on leading into that
convention because there is tremendous
internal discontent inside Democratic
circles but Chris when I'm reading the
stories about Biden's fundraising they
do expect to have taken in $67 million
in the last reporting and just in the
last few weeks I think they've raised
another 15 million they are outraising
Republicans and that's not nothing that
is something as you're going into an
election year is it
not and they've been outraising
Republicans over and over again and race
after race and it always very often does
make a difference now Donald Trump
proved that you can be outraged by your
opponent and still win but I think 2016
was really an outlier on that and that's
that's something the Republicans ought
to be worried about here is that Joe
Biden's seeming to show massive collapse
at the polls I think the polls
overstated most of the time but it seems
to be a collapse right now we're still
pretty far out from this election
there's still a real chance of that
money coming in and his ability to try
and to try and move the voters and get
them excited again about his policies
could have an impact if you're the other
party if you're the Republican party you
want to see this kind of collapse in Joe
Biden's popularity 2 months before the
election not
now well there's some interesting ads
that are already popping up Ari this one
made me howl laughing and I want people
to laugh on a Monday night so
watch hey President Biden is Obamacare
still a thing is it still a thing yes
Obamacare the Affordable Care Act Biden
care whatever you call it yes it is
still a thing will'll keep fighting to
protect it not just protect it but
expanding saving millions of dollars for
Working Families yeah it's still a
BFD Ari you know a lot of the folks that
make these ads I mean they're not even
looking into the camera I mean this is
just a bad ad so if they're paying a lot
of money for this stuff I don't think
Biden looks good by comparison to Obama
at all I think he looks
smaller when your job approval is in the
30s you need to be left out of all your
ads they they just won't work as soon as
you remind the American people that the
president is Joe Biden they're going to
turn their backs on that ad except for
hardcore Democrats and even many of them
have given up on Joe Biden so they they
do have a problem money will be a big
factor but the thing the Democrats have
to hope for is that the economy turns
around if there's any one thing that
could help the Democrats it is that the
stock market continues to hit record
highs all the way throughout the 2024
year that inflation gets low and stays
low without that I see Zero chance for
Joe Biden to win and that's against
Donald Trump that's against whoever the
Republican nominee is that's the one
chance they have and it's out of their
control well Chris I'll I'll remind
everybody about what the Biden people
were saying about the stock market when
it was near record highs under Trump
they said that's for rich people stock
market's not a real indicator so all the
Republicans need to do is to get a
montage of those sound bites just
playing back at
them yeah that would work but I mean
also at the end of the day inflation is
what a lot of people really are feeling
I mean the Biden Administration can lie
about how success is around the corner
in Ukraine that's something that's
difficult to verify by the average voter
maybe they don't care they can say the
border secure which is that lie is
starting to come apart as illegal
immigrants are pouring into blue cities
in the north but you're not going to be
able to get around how incredibly
expensive it is to shop for Christmas
this year how much money it cost to get
a roast beef for your family or some
other kind of meat how much steak costs
how much ground beef costs how much
chicken costs these things are you can't
lie your way out of and they're they're
trying but every time someone goes to
the grocery store they're reminded of
the difficulties of this
economy and Ari they don't really seem
to get these major issues that the
voters keep saying we need this
addressed and and I'm talking obviously
here about the border and it seems like
Jen saki who had your old job is worried
that Biden might actually do something
watch this this is something that the
base voters in the Democratic party will
hate and will be outraged by and there
will be a lot of people in the White
House who will not love details of this
but in the general election electorate
there is a fear of chaos at the border
border security it's a real issue it
doesn't mean it's entirely valid but
it's a perception
challenge well it's a it's always a
perception problem they perceive it to
be a problem Ari but it is a problem in
in every major city and even in sub
now yeah and thank goodness for the
Republican Governors who flew a lot of
these people who came to America
illegally to Martha's Vineyard to New
York City to Chicago so the rest of the
nation would see it not just Texas and
the border states um but you know Jens
saki's right about that the base of the
Democrat party does not want reform the
system they want open borders they want
people flooding into America most
Americans want to live in a nation with
governed by the rule of law where we
allow people in if they're supposed to
come and we want immigrants but you got
to come here legally and that's
something where I just don't think Joe
Biden's going to make the deal he still
governs from The Bernie Sanders wing of
the democratic party and that's what
he's done since day one with the
spending blowouts and all the different
things that he has done as president
he's always caved to the base of the
democratic party he wasn't like that as
a senator he is like that as a president
and that is one of the biggest reasons
he's collapsed as president he is
governing from the farle and is to his
own detriment and to our country's
detriment Chris I think the images of
thousands and thousands of people many
of them working age men th tens of
thousands of Chinese coming into the
United States I I don't see that that is
something that they can you know message
away or make a slit commercial and make
people forget about these images I don't
think it works at all not on this
issue and you know and you made a good
point and a great point in the angle
earlier where they were you were saying
the we're not a victim right now of some
kind of unforeseen circumstances forces
outside of our control there's not a
World War raging or something like that
a depression that suddenly hits these
are actual policy decisions the
decisions were seen at the border the
decisions that got we going through in
New York City the decisions in my
hometown of Washington DC those are
suicidal policies that are being
maintained by liberal politicians who
refuse to change course and it's and
it's making it now that the illegal
immigrants have been spreading
throughout the country country and
people are seeing it taking over aspects
of their City taking taking over the
homeless shelter in downtown Washington
DC they're starting to actually feel the
results of this that's another thing
that the administration either they need
to change course and I don't think they
will no this is a fanaticism that it
cannot be ignored Ari Chris great to see
both of you thanks so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it any where
else